enfer d'une course présidentielle monsieur
même [ __ ] de coke hella faites de vous un de
bourbon et de mauvais choix avec une sécurité
à des niveaux sans précédent ce n'est pas seulement
un rassemblement des dirigeants les plus puissants du monde,
c'est l'événement le plus protégé au monde
, bienvenue à Londres m.  président
qu'est-ce qui ne va pas
rien ne me dérange non Jack
a décimé la capitale britannique cinq
des dirigeants du monde sont maintenant morts nous
vous ferons sortir d'ici
le président américain
est porté disparu pour nos amis de
West Rockaway numéro six sur la liste des dix
que voulez-vous que votre
président ne se produise pas alors chaque
défi à partir de ce moment sera sur
votre tête nous devons renvoyer le lâche
avant qu'il ne renvoie le président nous
allons le tuer lentement et le
diffuser en direct ouais eh bien vous devriez  'ai apporté
plus de mana je ne serai pas exécuté comme
propagande
vous ne les laissez pas me prendre c'est une
torture pour me tuer c'est un ordre
Londres n'est que le premier arrêt
imaginez juste chaque grande ville
dans le chaos votre président meurt ce soir
pour  ceux qui menacent notre liberté l'
Amérique se lèveront bien ici nous y allons
et ne nous y trompons pas nous vous trouverons
et nous vous détruirons
Mike nous vous faisons sortir de
votre course d'horloge tout de
suite
oh m  ton dieu